good morning believe nation today's
message is it's good to fail over to you
Tom Hardy especially if you're coming up
with something from nothing which is
presumably what we will do in the
creative Department is that why I'm
selling a handful nothing and and hoping
to come through with some some results
and I'll put myself right out there for
the risk of it and I will fail and it's
okay to fail in fact you learn more from
failing and humiliation in my game than
than any than any other that I know and
actually that seems to be quite similar
across the board in most professions for
the people that I've met so it's good to
fail it's no embarrassing and
humiliation is your friend at first
glance you might think it's good to fail
how does that make sense I want to
succeed and the thing that you have to
understand is the people who've had the
most success with the people who failed
the most failure means you're trying
feeling means you're going out there and
trying to do something new trying to
grow trying to develop trying to learn
along that path the success of figuring
out what works you have to also figure
out what doesn't work if you're trying
to you know grow a plant you have to
understand this is gonna be rainy days
if there were no rainy days you wouldn't
have the water to grow a plant and so it
you will have rainy days in your life in
your business trying to figure that out
and that helps you grow to do the create
something amazing I think the people who
play their life so say for their
business so safe that they don't think
any failure means that they're not
taking any risk at all and they're not
living happily
I think the key with failure is one to
do it on a small scale whenever I have
an idea for something I want to test it
on a small scale how can I find the
smallest way to get started on this and
not involve a lot of money and not
involve a lot of people not and not
making this big huge production how can
I start with me today with one small
thing just to see see if I like it see
if it works see if I'm getting momentum
see if I fall in love with it see if I
want to continue doing it so many people
build up this huge thing and then they
never take action or where they do it
has to work or they're gonna be
you know they're gonna kill themselves
sometimes they actually do or it's such
a big thing that if there are so afraid
of feel that they never even take any
action because they're they that fear of
failure is immobilizing so it's fail
smaller start smaller start immediately
with some kind of action towards
achieving whatever your goal is and then
not having this insane emotional
attachment to failure part of being I
think a success in any field from an
athlete to an entrepreneur to a musician
you know you will fail you will get
rejected you will lose that race
sometimes nobody wins all the time and
so not having an insane emotional
attachment that prevents you from moving
forward and getting up and getting
better as long as each time you do it
you're learning something new right as
long as you have learned it's not a
failure if you go out and do the same
thing again and again and again and
again and again and you're not getting
results so maybe you need to change your
approach and change your tactic but as
long as you were learning from it and
you go out and do something a little bit
better a little bit different the next
time then it's not a failure
and so failure failure is a good thing
you need to fail but you've success so
the question of the day today is I'm
curious what are your thoughts on
failure what did you grow up being told
failure was all about what beliefs have
been put on you from you know your
parents and the people around you around
failure super curious to find out leave
in the comments below I'm gonna join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to John cousins John
thank you so much for pre-ordering a
copy of my book it really really really
means a lot to me
those are you guys watching you want a
chance at a shout out in the future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and email in your receipt so we can
keep track and send you the bonuses
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events pressive
more His grace how give me go